dans les yvelines il a été décidé de de
prendre le thème du sport du sport
scolaire et de le ps et les interactions
qu'il y ait entre entre ces différents
ces différentes disciplines et ses
différents milieux de manière à
favoriser le développement d'une
jeunesse le plus sportif
[Musique]
c'est nous faire connaître à faire
connaître notre discipline parce qu'on
se rend compte que depuis quelques
années elle a été un petit peu attaqué
un par les différents ministères en
l'occurrence un ya par exemple eu des
preuves spécifique de ps au niveau du
brevet des collèges au niveau du dnb il
ya eu aussi au niveau du bac avec la
réforme la dernière réforme des lycées
l'importante le ps a été minorée et
pourtant c'est la seul acte la seule
discipline qui est présente de la 6ème
jusqu'à la terminale quelles que soient
les filières
l'activité physique et sportive est
fondamental selon moi donc ça fait
partie bien sûr des disciplines
obligatoires à l'école donc c'est
important pour la santé pour
l'épanouissement de nos élèves pour pour
leur faire acquérir une culture sportive
bien évidemment un puisque bas plus on
va être en capacité à l'école
d'apprendre de choses dans les
différentes activités sportives et
artistiques plus nos élèves auront à
coeur ou ou oseront davantage aller dans
les clubs sportifs pratiquer des
activités en dehors que ce soit voilà le
savoir nager un 100 fait partie bien
évidemment